all right one of the stories circulating  in kansas city is a bus driver  apparently taking the raiders  around the stadium following their win  back on october  yeah but gruden isn't taking the  low-hanging fruit there and the chiefs  are  trying to throw him into that tonight  you'd expect gruden to brush it off and  he did  not really i mean you could find a smart  aleck bus driver in kansas city who made  some snide comments  when we got on the bus maybe that's why  we drove around the stadium just to  tick him off you know this is ridiculous  next question  all right fun stuff today sunday's game  with the chiefs will be  the first ever sunday night game  remember they're supposed to play on  sunday night with the buccaneers but  all the covid concerns move that game to  sunday afternoon